I want him to be our third best football
I think it was very cute you guys both
wear Jordans together it's really cool
Oh Jordan kiss huh I'm wearing the
greatest basketball player of all time
LeBron James thank you thank ya hey by
the way I'm also on that well let's talk
about another goat one that set the new
record this weekend Adam Vinatieri the
best most field goals made of all time
which is a quick like Morten Andersen
Gary Andersen I never thought those guys
could ever be caught like I thought they
were cyborgs you held for this guy but
like everything I see about you pat is
you have a great time you can part it
you can hold it down and everything I
see a Vinatieri is like you know he's
very buttoned up yeah I couldn't imagine
you guys get seriously I can't imagine
it either actually we were a very yin
and yang right situation yeah I was the
the 96 he was a man who had no idea what
to expect with me first of all when Bill
Polian drafted me I lied right to Bill
Polian face he said have you ever held
before I said absolutely I kicked and
punted in college I said absolutely bill
I hold all the time in practice I knew
that was gonna happen they draft me as a
punter to hold for the greatest kicker
of all time yeah Venna Terry calls me to
congratulate me he knew that I kicked in
college so he said have you ever held
before and I said absolutely not a slide
right the pole Ian's face I'm so sorry
so he flew me to Ken Walter who was his
holder in New England in North Carolina
for like a weekend for like a holding
like boot camp Wow laces out oh it's a
whole operation because if you're off by
that much if you've missed if I miss a
finitary misses a kick right and I'm the
rookie idiot punter it's a hundred
percent my fault yeah no one's way
without ya so we had a rough start but
we became very close friends I was I was
there to keep it light he was very
serious yeah silk around I called him he
was old obviously I was young we had a
good time he shared some stories about
back in his day whenever he was wearing
leather pants on Letterman and winning
Super Bowls and the whole thing and then
it just he's a he's a great human being
I can feel the respect you have for him
I own as well as for a long time I mean
it's seven years of ball holding for the
guy and he was just so damn good so
there has been an issue it seems like
for the last few years
err I don't know it's just not
guaranteed anymore and I don't know who
to blame this year okay seems to be
worse than worse than it yeah every us
and I don't know why I cuz you've got
the old heads who are still there
Janikowski still knocking on game
winners he had I miss the other night
though yeah Sunday yeah Dawson missed
one - the old heads I don't know what it
is either the extra-point thing though
you think that's just like not being
able to see like the free throw goes
through the hoop like getting that easy
short extra point did that help the
kickers confidence I think for the young
guys right it's a whole different ball
game you know because you go in hi sir
in college you kick off a guy for air
catches they get the ball to 25 like the
kicking in college is a joke there's
never any punt returns the field goal
it's just it's harder hash marks but
it's it's a joke you get the NFL you got
millions of dollars on the line millions
of dollars right and kicking is just
like golf it's in between your your ears
basically so when you think about the
added pressure the billions of dollars
the millions of dollars for your family
that really can go and do it in a
33-yard extra point is no longer just a
layup anymore it is something you have
to actually focus on especially if
there's a little bit of wind so I think
that could be something to it but
honestly I I think it's just guys
getting in their own head more I
honestly think it's are you rooting for
every kick to go in yeah yeah are you
yeah all right well I mean pressure I
always said when I was playing not when
you were playing but like I feel like
the field goal kickers are even though I
don't I bag on you guys sometimes or
kickers and punters to a degree right
you take it off I don't really
necessarily any punters more field goal
kickers Thank You punters are much more
yes can be physical specimen seriously
actually I agree hacker I also say with
kickers to like they are actually the
only people I always see on the field
that have true pressure footballs a
reactionary sport so Tom Brady could get
the snap on third and eight and yeah he
goes oh this is a big down but when the
ball gets snapped he's not still going
oh this is a big down he's going oh I
have to get out of the way this pass
rusher or I have to read the coverage
and then the pressure is gone out of
that right yeah where the kicker and
even the holder yeah like I would find
that being like oh crap I hope I catch
this and put it down good and I grew up
playing soccer okay if you're having a
bad soccer day you can put in more
effort right so you can like put in more
effort you can try harder on the
defensive side of the ball you can go a
little harder when it comes to kicking
and punting if you're having a bad day
you can't out effort anything the whole
world sees it there's no anything like
that if you there's a lot of thought to
write so you sit on the sidelines write
your size oh gosh this is a big moment
it's a whole different animal and
whenever people say well kickers and
punters aren't football players I think
to an extent it's pretty true to be
honest because your mindset is just so
much different my mindset is so much
different than football players it's I
hope I don't mess up I hope I set up my
defense here I hope we have a good time
but there's a lot of just sitting there
and cooking on it like man I hope I
don't do this I hope I don't do this I
hope I don't do this and it's just like
a golfer you know it's just you can get
the yips
it's kind of what happened there - Chris
Boswell from the Steelers he just made
20 mil and then he got the yips a little
bit and you can kind of get in your own
head and you're off and running it's
very different than an effort position
Yeah right
I said we should look at the guys then
like Dixon for Seattle or Justin Tucker
for Baltimore as a kicker
we should really marvel at them then
that I they're never in their own heads
it seems well Dixon had an 11 yarder on
Monday Night Football or something like
that because it was a bad snap I think
he's gonna be legit legit but if you
look at guys like boring boring ass
Thomas Moore stood right he's down in
New Orleans Saints boring dude he was my
roommate at a kicking punting camp I
think he's like an engineer of some sort
real tall he likes to drink but he's a
boring nerd what a boring nerd rizzo a G
or no kind of yeah that time kind of get
that yeah yeah kind of as quarterbacks
have to be okay yes have to go a little
bit yeah
talk about nerds Andrew Luck oh my god
another guy that I think I feel like you
and him are diametrically opposite you
yes he's so much smarter than me I would
assume a lot of people but me in
particular yeah like SAT words where you
have to he's just using things in his
just stream-of-consciousness yes is way
over my head does he ever cut loose I
think he has some craft beers every once
in a while I think he's in craft beer
guy which makes me fond I like the
chugga-boom beers what about Jim Irsay
though that's Ramaiya the man the owners
box
with the Indianapolis Colts has a
special glass in case because he's
burning fish oh he can smoke cigs in the
stadium and watch the game and it's
probably the only one I don't know how
it's legal but I guess when you own the
team you can do whatever you want just
built a glass box to smoke cigarettes oh
yeah I know poke his head out every once
in a while whenever there was a special
guest they'll give the way
the jumbotron place will go crazy back
into the glass it is these things you
think he smokes in the game I'm not sure
I honestly have no idea how many heaters
he came out in like a filtration system
in the glass box it's also very stressed
- okay he's an owner that does live and
die with the team I've heard the stories
of whenever I shank a punt that there's
like a god damnit McAfee who can't in
the glass tanks right so he is the guy
that lives and dies with his team that's
also whenever I retired I had a great
conversation with that man though I have
a lot of respect and appreciation for
Jim Irsay
sounds like it was a hell of a
conversation well he I mean we took me
on a trip you know he's like when you
become a boss or you can be able to make
the big decisions it's like today I was
asked to do I want to get a yacht in the
Caribbean who do I want to run a 757 and
live like the Sheik I'm like I don't
know something I don't know don't want
to do decisions are tough and you think
people are gonna be positive or do you
think people are gonna be negative I'm
like I'm not sure probably a little bit
of both you know they say the people
that are positive they see the glass is
half-full and the people that are
negative they see the glass is
half-empty I've always said get a
smaller glass the son of a bitch's food
I saw yeah it was a there was ninety
minutes of just magic with the guy what
did you get on your Wunderlich score
pretty good actually I'm really good
holy crap like 24 yeah I've been able to
tell that the show com pre-order Pat
McAfee professional baseball player
where I never played baseball day in my
life right
I played professionally in a minor
league game we recorded the whole thing
through your professional professional
baseball B yeah that you're the man dude
we appreciate it oh you guys are awesome
thank you so much for having me